c'est un endroit tenu secret en
direction de la frontière russe à
proximité des régions opéré deux groupes
de volontaires russes il s'agit de la
Légion liberté de la Russie et le corps
des volontaires russes ils ont mené une
opération spectaculaire dans la région
de Belgorod il ne partage pas la même
idéologie mais emmener une opération
conjointe avec un but commun renversé
par les armes le maître du Kremlin
le premier objectif nous voulons arrêter
la guerre en Ukraine le deuxième
objectif nous voulons le changement de
régime de Poutine nous voulons libérer
notre pays nous et le corps de
volontaire russe nous sommes un peu
différents ils sont de droite nous
sommes plus centristes mais nous faisons
une chose ensemble nous allons lutter
contre le régime de Poutine c'est notre
propre affaire entre russe la guerre
civile
je ne cache pas nos opinions nous sommes
de la droite traditionaliste
conservatrice je ne pense pas que ce
soit un problème je me fiche de comment
les Russes m'appellent ils continuent de
nous appeler par des noms comme traîtres
nazis néo-nazis alors pourquoi
devrions-nous nous en préoccuper
ce week-end
participe à la préparation de la
contre-offensive les soldats russes
mobilisés pour défendre leur propre sol
non pas été envoyés au front l'effet
psychologique lui est décuplé d'abord
pour les autorités
ukrainiennes il s'agit de montrer ses
héros russes qui combattent de leur côté
et pour ses volontaires russes le
message est aussi à destination de leur
concitoyens la guerre n'est plus une
opération spéciale dans un pays étranger
mais luth armée sur leur propre sol